The producer sat down with me and
[music] he says, "You know, we got
something very important we need to talk
about. The game's going to do well.
You're going to make a lot of money."
And he says to me, "What do you really
want? Mansions? You want cars? You want
women, boats, you want airplanes?" He
says to me, "Would I sell my soul for
even greater opportunities than this?" I
mean, honestly, within 5 minutes of
meeting this guy in person, I knew that
there was something very wrong here.
Very wrong.
>> I was heavily heavily into video games.
like not just The Sims, which we have a
video on by the way, but also uh Grand
Theft Auto. I went did San Andreas. I
did the did Grand Theft Auto 4. I did
Call of Duty. I was a bit of a tomboy
growing up. You know,
>> you played some of the heavy hitters.
>> Yeah, I did. I did. You know, did all
lots of online video gaming. We had a
Nintendo Wii. We had Nintendo DS Light.
We had a PlayStation at one point, an
Xbox 360. So, it was like like my
parents gave me a Game Boy Color when I
was really young. That was like the
second game board that came out at the
time after the the first game board that
was I think it was just black and white.
So I kind of grew up with this stuff and
then I watched uh Robert and Marlo's
video on uh video games actually and
talking about like who really runs the
industry. It's quite fascinating and I
was like wow this is crazy. So they're
here today to kind of walk us through
what they found. And then Jeremy's with
us as well on Zoom because he worked in
the industry and Jeremy, you're here to
during the conversation, too. So welcome
to everybody.
>> Thank you.
>> Marlo, Robert, what do you guys have for
us? Like what what research did you look
into to figure out like there's
something really sinister going on with
this industry?
>> Yeah. So for us to really understand
where you know who's actually
controlling most of these industries in
the world you know we we obviously we've
done our um uh research on music and
Hollywood and we even uh saw some of
your your videos on Hollywood and we
actually use some of them in our music
presentations. But to really understand
what's you know what's going on we and
we we received a question on gaming and
we thought wow this is an interesting
>> topic to really dive deep in and see
what you know who's actually behind the
gaming sector. So obviously as we know
if you look at who controls the world we
have to go back to the 1500s we have to
go back to the reformation period the
counterreformation period where Ignatius
>> really
>> that is that is where we went back to to
see where did it all start and look at
the money trails
>> and look at um you know the movements in
all these markets and where the Jesuit
order that was founded by Ignatius of
Lyola in 1540
where where the tentacles have spread in
this world.
>> Wow. I know it takes a lot of money to
make these games sometimes they are
employing hundreds and hundreds of
people to make these things right and I
always wondered like I guess when you're
making that much money there's a lot at
stake and I always wondered where are
they getting all this money to start
these things. So this is that I'm
looking forward to this conversation.
>> But if you look at the the the industry,
you look at the finances, you know, and
you see how prominent the gaming sector
is in our world, you know, and you look
at um for instance, uh Hollywood and you
look at it's around about a 32 billion
industry
>> and then you look
>> Yeah. And you look at the music, I was
thinking music industry would be
incredibly high, you know, music in
Hollywood, but gaming is more than
double more than double the combination
of Hollywood and um the music industry
out there.
>> Yeah. It's almost four times the revenue
in the gaming sector than in music and
movies. I've heard that like the the
sports arena where they do like the EA
sports kind of games um are sometimes
greater than like all the sports put
together,
>> right?
>> Like they're generating that much money.
>> I did not realize that cuz I I always
thought that gaming was kind of niche.
Like you always think of like well more
men game more than women is what you
kind of hear, right? And and like when
you meet people it's everybody's into
movies, everybody's into music, but not
everybody's into video games. So it's
crazy that there's so much money going
around in that.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And I mean who's who's
controlling the money? Who's controlling
who who controls the the banking systems
in this world? You know, if you look at
and and and we can uh we can show you a
a a diagram maybe um we can pull it up.
If you look at the the Jesuit order,
what was the aim? The aim was to counter
the reformation. So the aim was to keep
us in a system or in a Babylonian system
and that's what the reformation was
trying to escape from but they're trying
to keep us in there. So if they control
the money systems, if they control the
banking, if they control the medical
world, if they control the politics and
all the industries out there, then they
have us exactly where they want us.
So the you have the the the Templars,
the Knights of Templars, and if you go
look at their their function in history,
you'll see that it was in finance. And
that's really interesting.
And if you look at the Knights of Malta
and that's where the Maltes cross comes
from, you'll see that uh it originate or
that it's in the medical system. So
you'll see the Maltese crosses on your
ambulances and on your medical kits.
>> Interesting.
>> So
>> wow.
>> So they control that that whole sector.
>> Um and you wanted to say something about
the Jesuit connection here.
>> Yeah. Just before that if you look at
the world you see so many different
things. You see different religions. you
see different different political
parties and all of those things, but in
the end there's only two sides. You
might think that it's this side, this
side, and another side, but it's only at
the end the devil against God.
>> And one side tries everything in their
power to destroy the other side. And God
there is protecting us and calling us
out of these systems not to be hurt, not
to be damaged or destroyed, but to be
restored to what he wants for us. M
>> and when we realize that we see that the
Jesuits who are the people who want to
take you away from the Bible, who wants
to take you away from God, implement all
of these different kinds of tactics to
in the end destroy us.
>> Yeah. And what is that system? Babylon
is a system of idolatry.
>> Jeremy, did you notice anything about
that in when you were working in the
gaming industry? Like did you know did
you was there something you saw that
just made you feel uncomfortable about
hey there's there's a battle between
good and evil going on here?
>> Well I'll tell you what the producer of
this thing couldn't go 5 seconds without
saying something negative about the
Bible or Christ. How about that?
[clears throat]
>> This wasn't really the industry. this
wasn't really the industry, but this was
a
>> powerful
um [snorts] organization between it, but
beneath it anyway, that um
>> I mean, they really wanted to recruit me
and my skills and abilities for not just
this, but I, you know, a whole career
that they would have had laid out for me
if I had um you know, fully gone all the
way with it. I mean, honestly, within
five minutes of meeting this guy in
person, um, I knew that there was
something very wrong here. Very wrong.
But, uh,
>> you know, I I think I was shocked. I
didn't grow up playing all these games
and and I can remember when we first did
a couple documentaries on on the the
whole topic of of video games. I was
actually shocked at how many religious
ideas make it into these things. But
it's not like, you know, religious ideas
that that they're like promoting this as
as a good thing. It just seemed like it
was always an attack, always a, you
know, breaking down of of, you know,
they're the villains and, you know, you
need to use magic and sorcery to win.
And, you know, it's
>> it's kind of that one step further than
just passively watching. It's like what
you do with movies. You just passively
watch those. True. But this is actually
like making that decision that that
character is going to shoot that guy in
the head or whatever, you know.
>> Yeah. Well, and even like when I did a
video on the Sims, you know, I was
played the Sims for years, you know, and
and that was another thing my parents
introduced me to. My I remember very
clearly that for uh I think it was like
it was a Dutch holiday similar to
Christmas and my parents gave me a a
burned copy of The Sims, like not the
original game, you know, like it was
like stolen from the internet like here
you can have this video game. That was
my int first introduction to it. And
then so I made the video about the Sims.
Um, I showed that, you know, you're
you're able to now play your character
as a ghost, you know, like live your
whole life as a ghost, as speak speaking
to the dead, which the Bible speaks very
much against. You're able to befriend
the ghosts. Your Sims and your Sims are
able to have relationships with the
ghost, marry the ghost, take selfies
with the ghost. I mean, that's it's just
full-on spiritualism, but you don't it's
packaged in this cartoony kind of way.
>> And that's just one of the games, you
know. Um, you know, it's also very much
strongly promoting homosexuality. In
fact, I don't know if you guys saw that
video. I think Marley, you said you saw
the video I did on the Sims, right?
Where I kind of showed these things.
>> Yes. Yes, I saw it. I think that that's
one of the first videos I saw that you
produced.
>> Yes. Yes. Yeah. So, in in that video, I
also showed that simply you just slow
down the ads for the Sims and they have
fullon like lesbians kissing each other
in there, but you don't see because it's
so quick, you know, all those images on
purpose, but when you slow it down, it's
like right there in your face multiple
times. So, um yeah, there's there's a
very strong fight, I would say, against
religion in video games. Halo, same
thing. Lots of religious themes. Um, I
would say Assassin's Creed as well, and
that's a big franchise that lots of
people have played, myself included.
>> And it's interesting how they
systematically lead you to the to the
more sinister type of games. Imagine
where it started with Snake or whatever.
Even Snake had a had an agenda there.
And Mario Brothers, remember you
mentioned Nintendo and um and then I
mean the games that you see today. I
mean, we can show you um some of the the
covers of um Warcraft. And I mean, all
the Warcraft um slogans are really
interesting. I mean, look at this. It is
wroth of the leis king or the war
within. Isn't that interesting?
>> The war within.
>> Tides of darkness,
reign of chaos. That's what it's about,
>> you know. Or Diablo.
>> It's all about I mean, it's basically
satanic. They're satanic. Yeah. And
>> yeah, Diablo means Satan. Yeah.
>> You mentioned Nintendo and it's
interesting to see the creators of these
consoles, of these brands, you know,
when you look at um Hiroshi Yamachoi, I
mean, he was a Japanese. And who do you
think he he he he climbed in bed with um
in in the industry, you know, to to make
to make a mark for himself with Walt
Disney? And I know Scotty and or both of
you know Walt Disney quite well from
Hollywood and how he's permeated into
all these industries. How's that
possible? How does that work?
>> Walt Disney's really um and I think
people have not um really kind of made
that connection. I'm talking like the
people in the general population have
made that connection that that really
they are bringing this candycoated
witchcraft to everybody. And we've seen
in in our day and age a super rise in
spiritualism. And you know it's like
today like people don't even think twice
about it. And you know they watch us
really there's spiritualistic stuff in
there. And it's like yeah
>> everywhere. [laughter]
>> But you know I I I think the the gaming
industry is is just taking it one step
further. There's a lot of money at stake
and yeah, I'm fascinated by um you know
what you guys are kind of bringing to
the table here is it's like some of this
money goes all the way back to the
1500s.
How do you see that line to to today?
Oh, the the the money. So they they
obviously control all the banking
systems. I know there was a a man I
don't I can't remember the article, but
it was Jacob Sheff. he was a a 33 degree
and he was in charge of the banking
systems in in America uh amongst other
things. So he had to he had to ensure
that the banking systems belong to the
order and that's when you look at black
rockck I mean black rockck is also
involved you know in the gaming sectors
and Hollywood and Vanguard and all these
these top companies in the world who own
like 70% of the world who actually owns
Black Rockck hey so just just back at um
Walt Disney before we get into the money
is he was he has a membership card of
the order of demollay A which is very
interesting.
>> So you know demia that's the that's your
youth that's your base level fraternity
um in your freemason system. You have
your Scottish rights and you have your
York rights. You have your more esoteric
agenda on the one end and you have your
medieval chivalry on the York right side
and your your uh Christianity uh
Christian mythology and all of that. But
you have your baseline and that's where
they train the youth and he was a part
of this. So while Disney is he's
definitely a Freemason that we know and
that's yeah and that's how he obviously
uh weaved his way into the gaming sector
to a large degree actually. Yeah.
[snorts] They're building up ideas
through movies through his theme uh
sorry through his theme parks and all of
those things that when a game comes out
you're familiar with the concept and the
characters and then you want to play it.
I remember watching Harry Potter that
series or the series of movies and
afterwards I felt to myself if this
could only be real it would be so
amazing because why wouldn't you want to
cast a spell to levitate something and
they make it so exciting that when the
games came out you can actually play
this character now and then you can have
this virtual thing happen in front of
your eyes. It doesn't feel virtual
anymore. Now you're a part of it. Now
you can build your legacy like Hogwarts
legacy. You can play the character of a
wizard that was introduced through the
movies.
>> Takes you away from reality though. Hey.
>> Yeah. We we did just did a show um on
the the Bowen Brothers channel and uh
their heritage and hope and it was
pretty amazing. like one of the one of
the ladies that was on there with us had
had just you know grew up kind of
playing around with the with the Harry
Potter books and and you know interested
in those kind of movies and and stories
and then she found herself you know
buying the cauldron and you know buying
the you know souvenirs and and all of
those things kind of came into her life
in a way of like in the same way that
you just mentioned Marlo it you know
wouldn't it be neat if I could do
actually do those in real life. And when
you go to the bookstore, it's like the
the witchcraft books are right next to
these fake stories. And and it's a very
easy, you know, jump from the fake into
the real. And I think that's what's
happening with the video games, too.
>> And and she even said that um that that
she start seeing demons as she was
reading all these Harry Potter books and
one demon was even holding a knife and
all those kind of things. So, uh yeah,
it was some some pretty intense stuff.
And and like you guys are talking about,
it's it's all over the video games, too.
I mean, like it's it's in the Sims,
which like I said, seems so innocent,
but it's
>> because it's so cartoony, right? But but
it's really just testing the waters. And
again, I started with Nintendo. I
started with like the 101 Dalmaters game
and then like Super Mario Brothers game
>> and then it went into The Sims and later
on I was full-on playing Grand Theft
Auto where you're like basically killing
everybody around you.
>> But uh just a quick question for Jeremy.
Jeremy, what what was it for you cuz
what was it for you that got you into
the gaming and then eventually working
on something like that? Well, I mean,
for what it's worth, um, the only game I
was ever really super into was, uh, Doom
for the PC that I probably sunk tens of
thousands of hours into the custom
levels and all this, yada yada, but
otherwise, I really wasn't much of a
gamer.
>> Was for a gamer, but um, you know, I did
do a lot of art and animation. I posted
online and then, you know, uh, one day I
get an email saying, um, I'm starting
this project. Uh, it's going to have so
and so people in it. do you want to work
on it? And that's that's how it happened
with me, just getting involved in that.
And you know, eventually I did quit. I I
did walk away from it. And I mean, I
haven't touched anything like that
since. So,
>> you mentioned Doom there and I remember
I spoke to someone after we did our
gaming thing and he told me the only
game ever to give him nightmares was
Doom. He said he played it. I can't
remember if it's Doom 1 or 3 or around
there, but he said it was so satanic
with the pentagons and all the imagery
that you find in that game that it
actually gave him nightmares. He
couldn't sleep.
>> Well, I got nightmares when I when I
researched the top 10 gory games out
there just before we actually did, you
know, and it was insane what they what
they actually do. You can see limbs
being cut off and the blood squirting
out and it's just insane what what they
you know what's happening today.
>> That was one of the biggest reasons why
they hired me because they knew that the
death animations that I could produce
for all these characters would be just
so over the top and visceral and I mean
I really did sink my heart into a lot of
it too at the time I will say. So you
know that that was one of the big things
about it that they really wanted from
me. It's like you know we know you can
do this.
the graphic imagery.
>> The military are trained on on um
shooting games and the the school
shooters, they spent how many hours was
it? 13 hours or something a day or
something on on uh uh first person
shootout games
>> before they actually went into the
schools and committed those murders.
So, it just shows you what Yeah. the
effects of these games. We've been so
desensitized e over the years. Slowly
but surely they desensitize us over the
years.
>> Yeah. Your brain can't distinguish
between virtual and reality. So now when
you're actively playing the shooting
game, your brain isn't registering it as
this is something virtual that's
happening. It's registering it as these
people are being killed now.
>> Right. Well, you also have the Bible
verse, you know, that uh you know, if
you're angry with your brother, right?
And you know, it's it's like as if you
killed him. And so we know that the
actual act doesn't necessarily have to
be going through and shooting and
killing, but if you have that same
spirit and you're, you know, getting
enjoyment out of that or or you're
desiring for that thing to die, I mean,
it's like the devil's created this like
cartoonish version of things that we are
now making those things do these sinful
things, but really it's it's our own
brains that are desiring those things as
well. So, um I think that when you
really say, okay, I want to I want to
really fully order my life after after
what God is asking, um I think most
Christians would be like, I don't want
to play that kind of a game, you know?
>> Yeah.
>> And the creators of these games, like I
said before, Nintendo and um who was the
other guy? Um Aio, he was he was um he
he received so many of these uh awards.
Um and he was Sony. So your PlayStation
there was a Kio Morita. It was also
Japanese. All these all these creators
they were kned by the queen for their
contribution to society. Tell me what
contribution did they make to society?
You know, and and who is royalty? They
subservient to the once again to the
Jesuit order to the to the papacy.
>> Yeah, I think your father has a video on
that, right? I remember watching it.
Uh-huh.
>> Um, I think it was uh from Cree from
Malta to Creed or Creed to Malta, one of
those.
>> I think it's in that series if I'm
correct.
>> Or or it could also be rekindling the
Reformation.
One of one of those where he then states
or shows how the throne of England is
actually being rented back by the papacy
or by the queen from the papacy.
>> Wow. Where else do we have this in the
Bible though? Hey, remember Jahoo, king
of Israel, was subservient to to the
king of Is uh Assyria.
>> Hey, so he could reign in his sphere,
but he had to he was subject to the
king. And that's what we have on earth.
It's nothing nothing else, nothing
different under the sun. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. and and finding that link between
the Jesuits and the gaming industry or
the Freemasons and the gaming industry
is quite difficult because there's not a
lot of paper trails that are given in
the games. you can see the symbolism and
things like that, but a actual um
connection was quite hard to find. And
in our research, we were looking for it
and looking for it and eventually we
came across a article in the Chicago
Catholic, which was interesting because
the heading says how a game designer
turned Jesuit ended up writing about
space religion in another game. So in
the article it goes on it says that he
was busy experiencing um he was driving
in traffic he got angry for something
that happened and then he thought about
but this isn't right he wants to be
spiritual so how can he get angry for
people in the traffic and the articles
then starts here at this experience also
sent Lisa on a spiritual quest which
would eventually lead him to leave his
work as a designer for games like
Fallout and Skyrim and joined the
Jesuits
uh the same religious order as Pope
Francis.
>> Mhm.
>> So then he went and he asked, "But how
can he be in gaming and still be in the
Jesuit order and things like that?" And
the next part of the um the article said
that um his work on Starfield, the game
that he then designed, has led to
questions about whether writing games
could be part of his future ministry.
And then it says, "Jesuits have a long
history of working in the arts as um
sorry, in the arts and as writers.
Acclaimed playwright Bill Kaine, who
also wrote for the now defunct
television series House of Cards, is a
Jesuit priest. Jesuits have also
excelled at astronomy, education, and
other pursuits, said Jesuit Father Tom
Ree, a religion news service columnist.
Um, Ree said, "Jesuits work closely with
their superiors to find the right match
for their ministry." And then they said
there has to be a value ad that comes
from the Jesuit's participation
>> always.
>> So he went back into gaming. And if
you're a Jesuit, there has to be
something that's of value in the work
that you do. And if we look at the
reason why the Jesuits were formed to
counteract the reformation, that is the
same value that he needs to add. So in
this game that he's designing the
designing, he needs to add that value of
countering the reformation,
>> you know. Um, a while ago, a couple
years ago, we released a documentary
that kind of talked about the chosen.
And then I did a follow-up documentary
this year about the chosen and kind of
like the very very blatant if you look
into it secret society connections to it
like the Jesuits mainly but also you
know how they're collect connected to
Freemasons and the Knights Templars and
um in that documentary I I found I used
or I quoted this this study that was
done by a professor he was like a
professor in like theater in Los Angeles
something like that. He wrote actually
about the history of how the Jesuits got
involved with Hollywood and he talks
about how it started obviously with
Jesuit theater and the whole purpose was
as he quoted that they were trying to
use theater to bring people back to
Catholicism Protestants mainly because
that was their ultimate goal of the
Jesuits and he also wrote about how the
Jesuits at that time didn't care about
the genre anything would go as long as
it meant for the purpose of reaching
their goal of turning people back to
Catholicism. So even if it's like
violent or like romance or sexual didn't
matter they could use all of that as
long as they achieve their goal.
>> Yeah. The the the end justifies the
means is exactly the quote. Yeah. In
great controversy as well.
>> But I mean and and remember the online
gaming what was that called again? Um
Ebelin.
>> Yeah. Hey, Ebelyn. So, they find comfort
in playing online like Warcraft and all
of this. There was Ebelyn, I think, was
a um he was a sickly boy. I think he
died at the age of 25, but he had this
whole thing in a massive article on the
news about finding comfort on online
gaming and discovering himself and this
and and finding love and all of these
things in online game. But he's playing
Warcraft. He's killing people. He's
having relations with people online. You
know what I mean? And um and this is
good. This is a good thing.
>> Yeah.
>> Hey,
>> you know, it's sad. It's sad to me that
that God made this beautiful like gift
of life and and you know, these
relationships. I mean, that's really
what we're doing here, right? is a
relational um um I don't want to say
experiment but but you know we we are
living out this life that we need to you
know help our fellow brethren love on
people help ease their pain and
suffering and here we have this like
really strange like activity this
juxtaposition of of like instead of
helping we're wanting to destroy and and
you know it's like I got to collect and
gather as much money as I can so that
you know everybody else and you You
know, even on just a physical level,
these game industries, they don't care
that people are spending 8 9 10 11 12
hours at the detriment of their own
health, right?
>> And it's like, you know, people are are
really being destroyed playing these
things. It's not bringing happiness. I
mean, sitting in a dark room and staring
at a screen, uh, you know, if you saw an
animal do that, you would think that
that animal there's something wrong with
him. you know, true. It'd be like, you
know, why is he sitting there staring at
this box 12 hours out of the day, right?
>> And and so this cannot be good on our
brains, you know.
>> Yeah. No, I'm with you.
>> I would like to add that I mean this 8
to 12 hours a day that
>> So where's the parents?
>> Where are the parents in all this? M
>> you know um this is definitely a symptom
of the breakdown of society where uh
family is eroding and you know give the
kid a video game whatever just keep them
busy right and
like I wonder to see where where it's
all going to go even a generation or two
from now. Uh
>> it's um
>> it's very telling about the first world.
It's very telling about the first world
and um the economy of time and
everything all that and what it's what
it's going to be producing for the young
people of the upcoming generations. You
know, [snorts]
>> the parent is the video game system.
That that's what it pretty much turns
out to be. Mhm.
>> And the designers and the creators, they
actually employ psychologists
to to make the game more attractive to
to have more gaming hours played on
their game so they can they can sink
people more into their their agenda into
their game so they can make more money.
The the Bible makes more and more sense
when it says money is the root of all
evil. Hey, it's just what it's all about
is making money. contribution money.
Bill Gates was also knited. He also he
was part of um Xbox. Hey, he was the
founder of
>> of of Microsoft. Exactly. I mean, they
all in the same pool here. They're all
playing this game together.
>> Hey, subscribe to Leos.
>> [music]
>> If you want to learn Spanish, [music] a
great way will be watching our videos
for practice.
Um, we also had a video showing someone
playing Fortnite and I think you guys
also did a video on Fortnite,
>> but the kid was he didn't go to school
for 2 years because he was playing
Fortnite. when someone came to his house
to interview him, he was busy playing.
He didn't even put the gaming console
down and when their parents turn off the
internet, if they turn off the console,
he gets violent physically and he starts
hitting his mom. That's how far he's
been pulled into this gaming sector.
>> Yeah. And and the Fortnite is
specifically was was to me kind of a a
shocker because it was designed in this
very like cartoony, bubbly world. I
mean, you know, if that was realistic,
um, you know, people might have been a
little bit more freaked out or alarmed
of that, but the fact that it would just
had that kind of like, you know, sort of
playful, bubbly look to it. Um, I
remember Keith mentioning one thing, one
of the other guys on our channel, um,
one time he said, you know, if you just
actually took those players that you're
actually trying to shoot, so you're the
last man standing and you swapped them
out with your family members, so those
those little uh characters became your
family, you know, would you would you
feel differently about that, you know,
as a Christian? What if they were Bible
characters? What if one of the guys was
Jesus? you know, would you feel
comfortable going and shooting him to
try and like dance over his dead body? I
think that there's there's something
sadistically wrong with that.
>> And he even said, "What if it's a bunch
of babies?"
>> Yeah. If it's a bunch of babies, like
like when you kind of change the the
look of it or the context of it, then
you then I think most people would be
like, "Yeah, yeah, that's not right.
That's that's disgusting."
But it's like
>> they're riding this very fine line of of
of you know,
>> yeah, it's a cartoon and it's just for
fun, but you're killing people and
trying to be the last person standing.
And to me, that's just not a heavenly
character trait.
>> No, not at all.
>> No. And speaking of Fortnite,
interesting. Uh that's Epic Games and
they also I mean they they integrate I
mean they they all integrated. So, Walt
Disney. So, it's it reads here actually
um Epic Games will bring together
Disney's beloved brands and franchises
with a hugely popular Fortnite in a
transformational new games and
entertainment universe.
So, everything is integrated. You can
you can games start uh being portrayed
in movies and and other way around. Hey.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And the article continues
where it says, "This marks Disney's
biggest entry ever into the world of
games and offers significant
opportunities for growth and expansion."
>> Yeah. I mean, if you want to go a little
bit deeper, you look at uh you look at
the Scottish rights and you look at the
York rights. If you go into the temple,
the Scottish rights temple, and I'm sure
you know about this, but you'll see the
the the symbolism is really interesting.
Hey, like you said in doom and all these
areas you have the symbolism but in the
Scottish right you have that sign of Anu
and then you have the sun god Shamash at
the top as you go in and the sign of Anu
the biggest sign of Anu well first of
all sign of Anu means is basically the
the mark of Cain it's the rulership over
evil
>> hey so so if you go if you look at the
largest sign of Anu in the world it's at
Vatican city
>> oh wow
>> is it you mean like the the sun dial in
the middle of the square
>> that if you look at it, you'll see the
you'll see the sign of Anu, the mark of
K.
>> And there they they are all
interconnected. And this is something
that I explained as well in that second
documentary, The Chosen, is that and I
actually got this uh your your dad kind
of helped me to understand this from his
videos, but that really the it it
started with the Knights Templars and
then the um when you look at Albert's
Pike book, morals and dogmas, and Albert
Pike is a 33rd degree Freemason who
wrote that book, which basically like
the way we hold the Bible as Christians
is like this is our book and this is our
literature. That's basically what that
book is to them. And he's Albert Pike
writes in there, yeah, the Knights
Templars, they're supposedly went
underground, but he's like, no, they
actually morphed into later on like the
Freemasons and all those kind of things.
And and the Knights Templars came about
as as an order by the Catholic Church as
well that was supposed to suppress
anybody. It started with suppressing,
you know, helping pilgrims that came to
Jerusalem to to protect their pilgrims
and eventually it became something that
where they suppressed anybody that was
speaking or standing up against the the
Roman Catholic faith. So, um it's just
another order that does the same thing
and and again they morphed into uh
Freemasonry. Later on, they went
underground.
>> Yeah, there's nothing new under the sun.
Everything that has been in the past is
still continuing now. And we're moving
towards a climate or climax of where
everything is going to end. But what
Satan is doing so masterfully is he's
creating all of these environments where
you can feel a sense of self-worth. Uh
if you play a video game, you can
accomplish things that you can't
accomplish in real life. You can be a
football star. You can be the best
person in the military, the highest
officer, you name it. You can achieve it
on that game and then you feel the sense
of self-worth. So you don't have to go
out and do something. You don't have to
go and read the Bible. You don't have to
look at what your identity is in Christ.
You can just be. There's no urgent or
there's no urge into something more.
It's just just relax. Be who you want to
be. It's a false security.
>> Yeah,
>> a false security. And it's all
disguised. I mean, if you become like
you said, if you're in if you're in a
high position in the military, whatever,
you become a you can become a Freemason.
But you you have no idea what's going on
in the bottom levels. Hey, it's only
when you start climbing those ladders
and once you hit the 32 level, it's too
late.
>> And your 33 degrees, that's a
significant contribution to society.
It's why most of these guys like Bill
Gates and all these guys are 33 degree
Masons because they have made that they
know what they're doing. They are aware
of the contributions that they are
making
>> to Satan's game.
>> Yeah.
>> Like a few months after this project
started. Um the producer sat down with
me and he says, you know, we got
something very I I usually don't talk
about this stuff, but um he says, you
know, we got something very important we
need to talk about. You know, he says,
um the game's going to do well. we know
it's going to do well. You're gonna make
a lot of money. Uh we're gonna be sure
that you're gonna have a career.
And then he says to me, "What do you
really want? What do you really want?
>> Do you want mansions? Do you want cars?
Do you want women? You know, do you want
boats? Do you want airplanes? What do
you really want?" He says to me, "Would
I sell my soul for even greater
opportunities than this?
>> You know, you're going to
believe whatever you want, you know, uh
but it happened and I laughed and it's
like what are you talking about? So like
even if they even if I had a soul um why
would I sell it to you for anything,
right?
>> Mhm.
>> And you know and he laughs and he pats
me on the back and says you know you
just think about it. You just think and
it never came up again. Never came up
again though. Um all sorts of other
things did over the next you know year
that I was over there. But I mean that
happened and
I mean I believe it. I absolutely
believe that if I had gone down that
rabbit hole, who knows where it would
have led to, man. Just interjecting with
that because you're saying, you know,
there's there's levels to it and all
this. And I mean, they wanted me, dude.
They wanted me.
>> I mean, we we we just look at today. We
look at now. Look at Katy Perry in that
interview. Hey, she's like, "Well, that
guy came to me and he said, "Do you want
fame? Do you want money?" And I said,
"And I sold my soul to the devil." Haha.
You know, it's really really cool.
>> Yeah. It's really
>> like there's there's these videos where
these celebrities are basically saying,
"Oh yeah, there's somebody behind the
curtain there, you know, and of course
most people might
>> Yeah. Oh, yeah. Sure, whatever." But and
it's a very different thing when it's
when it's staring directly across the
table from you, though. Very different
thing, man.
>> We we shot a video recently with a lady.
She grew up in the Caribbean and uh her
father was a high up voodoo priest. Very
high up. And when her father passed
away, she was the next person in line to
basically take over. And she was being
groomed to become the next voodoo
priest. And she had conversations with
Satan herself. She thought Satan was a
friend. Her father had conversation with
Satan. And she said there are many, many
celebrities, politicians even in the
United States who came down here who
would make sacrifices to Satan through
her father so that they could become
famous. and her father was even telling
them this is what you need to write in
your lyrics because this is part of the
deal. Um, so we know this is real. And
now she's a praise God, she's a
Christian. You know, she gave her life
to Jesus and was dealing with demonic
stuff for many years after that, but God
gave her victory over that and protected
her. But it's real. It's a real thing.
Even Beyonce's sister, right, she there
was a warlock, an interview on YouTube
with there was a warlock who became a
Christian and he said that he was also
somewhere in one of those countries, not
in the United States, working at this
witchcrafty, voodooike store. and
Beyonce's sister walked in getting some
some flies. So, you know, we know what
they're dealing with.
>> They they have to be part of their order
is to be transparent.
They they laughing, you know, they
they've deceived us in such a manner
that we we have no idea what's going on
anymore. They they have all the
symbolism which is on your Scottish
right side. You know, your symbolism,
it's everywhere in the world. The the um
in linguistic programming, you know, the
programming in cartoons and all these
things. I mean now I I watch I mean my
son does watch TV from time to time but
I'm very weary when it comes to what
he's watching. You know you you see
these symbolism you're like you know I'm
I'm not going to allow you to watch that
because I know what they're doing
>> and without you knowing they they they
get your children
>> you know they they they pull them into
this system. It's not just the passive
maybe one here, one there. You know, I I
think it kind of works on the same on
both sides of the fence. I don't think
that just because you you you listen to
one, you know, Bible text that all of a
sudden you're going to be like, "Oh, you
know, I'm I'm all in for God." Right?
It's a it's a sort of a building up and
you're kind of understanding and and
you're you're learning about, you know,
the government of God and and the world
that God has created for us. And the
more information that you have, the more
it solidifies in your mind. And uh I
think that the same way is true on the
other side. I don't think it's one video
game that all of a sudden you're going
to sign up for Satan, but it's just this
habitual constant like, you know, coming
back to that and getting worse and worse
and more, you know, crazier games and,
you know, crazier themes in those games.
And I think these kids don't realize or
or even adults. I think the majority of
people are in their 30s. I think that
that uh are playing some of these games
too sometimes. So, you know, it's just
that habitual thing. And um you know, if
you if you gave God a chance, just give
him the Daniel challenge, right? 40
days. I'm going to just, you know, spend
time with you, God. Just observe. This
is what I always tell tell young kids,
too. And when they're just like, "Oh,
you know, this is doing nothing to me
and I said, "Have you ever tried to
like, you know, just just give your
attention and your time to God and see
how that makes you feel?" I mean, I
think that there is some real proof in
the in the in the mental mind, the
clarity when you actually spend that
time with God as opposed to you're just
spending a month, you know, shooting and
killing everybody. And there's a there's
a big contrast between those two things.
And so, you know, if you're if you're on
the fence and you're questioning it,
give God a chance, try it, and you'll
see that it's it's much different.
>> I I want to add something to that since
you mentioned Daniel. So, um I mean,
this basically ties into how I'm even
here now talking with you. Um so, it was
the summer of 2015. Um I'd been invited
to live on Vancouver from Ireland to
work on the project. I was only out
there for about a year before I just
couldn't take it anymore. you know, all
sorts of stuff that have been going on.
So, I go back home. Um, it's summer
2015. I'm still working on this thing,
though. And [clears throat] I'm, you
know, I'm tucking into a long night of
drawing and I go to YouTube
and right there at the very top of my
recommended is an amazing facts video.
There is no
possible explanation for why this would
be there at all.
>> I'm not looking up any Christian media.
I'm not looking up anything like this.
Of course, at this point in my life, I
am seriously questioning a lot of things
and everything that's going on. And
there is this amazing facts video that's
in there. And it's specifically um about
uh the book of Daniel and all this
stuff. And um it's also the one where
Doug Bacher shows all the different
slides between like um you know, St.
Peter's Cathedral and uh how all
government buildings share the same
aesthetic and all, you know, all sorts
of stuff like that. And you know, I
watched this video and I guess I could
say that my life has been everything
before that video and then everything
after because I mean like it just blew
me away. Just absolutely blew me away.
The prophecies of Daniel and everything
like that. And [snorts] I mean I at this
point Yeah. No, I
I mean here I am talking with you,
[clears throat] you know, of course. Um
and for anybody who's listening who um
may be on the fence, uh you just got to
you just got to give it you just got to
go for it yourself, man. and and you'll
see you'll see you know uh it's it's not
fairy tales and it's not
>> but it's it's it's been it's been a
interesting ride so far let's let's put
it that way
>> yeah I I just wanted to add we need to
be really selective
>> how we spend our time you know and that
will form us you know do we spend our
time in the Bible and in the word and
and yes if you don't spend time in the
Bible the word it it is boring to even
consider it because you are so
encapsulated ated with the things of
this world. But and and we all we are
all sinful beings. So all of us,
everyone sitting around this table as
well. We all need to be wary of where we
spend our time. You know, even I when I
when I sit in my in in the evening, I
lie in my bed and I I watch a a u uh
what's that? Um
>> Tik Tok.
>> Tik Tok. Thanks. And you you're watching
Tik Tok and it's about a a cat and a dog
or whatever. the next one is like,
"Okay, but this is interesting." And
then you start getting carried away and
all of a sudden you you spent an hour
and you you haven't spent time with God
and you're so tired, you're like, you
know, I'm going to give a quick prayer
and I'm just going to go to bed. You
wake up in a storm. You know, everyone
is affected by it in the morning and you
are affected because you just that
little bit of, you know, selectiveness.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, after I uh
>> So true.
After I started reading the Bible and
came to Christ, I had this conviction
that video games, it's not the right
direction to go in, but a time went
past. And then you kind of convince
yourself, uh, but it's not that bad.
Maybe maybe the shooting games are bad,
but I'll just play sport games. I'll
I'll I'll go to the bad bad things and
just a sport game. And it started off
like that. and then before you know it,
you're back into the things that you
shouldn't play anymore.
>> Or for instance, you're playing sport
games and then you're starting after
work. You play a few rounds and then you
feel like you just want to accomplish
the next
>> race or the next goal or just the next
thing and before you know it, you've
been sitting there the entire evening.
you didn't sleep and then you skip Bible
because it's more important to get your
sleep now because you have to go to work
again. So all of that takes you away
from God.
>> And when he takes you away from God, God
wants us to have noble characters. He
wants us or yeah a noble character. He
wants us to have pure thoughts. He wants
us to have steadfast principles. But if
we don't spend time with him, if we
don't read the Bible and we spend time
with all of these other things, it's not
going to be easy to have a noble
character to be a good person.
>> And there's another element to it as
well.
>> Yeah.
>> And that is winning and losing.
>> Isn't a game always about winning and
losing?
>> Yep. It's true.
>> Hey, and I mean I enjoyed the same
happened to me. I really enjoyed
Starcraft. I don't know if you ever
heard of Brood Wars. It's a strategy
game and [snorts] man, I still recall,
you know, that I I would still enjoy it
if I played it. You know, you had the
aliens and the hybrids and the humans
and then you built bases and then you
attacked and after that and I was
sitting there playing a game and I and I
lost and someone just, you know, rubbed
me up the wrong way and I got so angry
and I think I hit my table or something
and it was after my conversion and my
wife's like, "What fell? What broke?"
And I was so embarrassed. I was like,
"Nothing. Something just fell." You
know, and and I thought to myself that
night, I I was lying in bed till 12:00.
I was like, "Okay, I got up. It was a 32
gig game." And I just said, "Delete."
Bam. And I just started deleting all my
games because that competitiveness, you
don't have to subject yourself to all of
that. Why do that? Yeah,
>> I think I think also for me, you know,
my personal conviction is that
like we we used to have a Nintendo Wii,
you know, but like that like the first
one with the remotes that you have to
hold and stuff like that and there it
always came with the standardbased game
of Wii Sports. I don't think there's
something there's anything inherently
evil about bowling on the Nintendo Wii
or playing tennis on the Nintendo Wii.
But I think for myself the the the the
the thought process I've come to is
if Jesus is coming soon, I believe he's
coming extremely soon. Like I think I
believe that his second coming is around
the corner looking at how Bible prophecy
is being fulfilled left and right. Then
then why would I want to spend even, you
know, an hour, 30 minutes playing a
video game when I could spend that time
either sharing about Jesus, learning
about Jesus, doing good unto others, you
know, something productive, something
that just even just grows my character,
like I don't know,
>> read a book,
>> read a book, do some gardening, like
learn something, you know. So, so for me
personally, that became a thing. No, I
haven't played video games in in years,
but just just personally it was it
became a conviction about how I spend
time on my phone, for example, how I
spend time on social media, how I spend
time on YouTube, where I thought, yeah,
Lord, but you know, if you're coming
this soon, why would I why would I want
to spend time on that when I want my
heart to be ready? I want to be prepared
for your second coming, right? Um so
yeah I think it also really is we are
living in a very different time and and
we need to be aware of that that Jesus
is calling our hearts say come and spend
time with me because and also in my mind
I just think well if my heart and my my
desire is still for you know let's say
video games or YouTube or social media
then I need to be careful that that
doesn't become a false god in my life
because if my heart longs more for that
thing than for God, then there's a
problem there.
>> And if I'm not going to have, you know,
YouTube, Facebook, social media, or
video games in heaven, then I need to be
willing to give it up now because
otherwise, how am I going to enjoy
heaven when it's like, oh man, all of my
my uh my my little favorite things are
not there. You know,
>> you know, you bring up an interesting
point. uh if you you know were raised on
on reading the Bible and like you know
even like as a little child reading the
stories and everything and if you took
those away would the child have a temper
tantrum
>> but yet if you have that with the video
games it's like you take that away and
it's like you can see the the draw and
the pull towards that.
>> Yeah. And I think, you know, kids are
kids, like they they see the exciting
colors and the, you know, the challenges
and things like that to play that. And
uh and I think that uh we we we rob them
of these precious moments, especially
when they're little when their brain is
being formative in those formative
years.
>> Um to set them on really healthy things
that that that would encourage their
growth either mentally or physically.
And uh you know we're not meant to be be
indoors for long periods of time or
sitting there um just doing nothing with
eating junk food you know right
>> so
>> sounds like Sodom and Gomorra idleness
was the the reason for the destruction
actually one of the reasons
>> and and we we always gravitate I mean
Romans 7 always says we always gravitate
towards evil and it's our duty as well
>> right
>> to fight against those urges like I said
you know Tik Tok and Then you go into
the motion, you know, what do you do
when you get up get up from bed? You
know, do I? And and a lot of the times I
don't pray first. I go, "Oo, wait. I I
had an email to quickly check for work
or this or that." And then you you you
check again and you and you haven't
prayed and you're in that state again.
Hey, you have to make it, you know,
military style. You have to do it in a
religious tone. It's it's already so
difficult
without these influences just trying to
do the correct thing. So why do we want
to go and make it more difficult for
ourselves? Why do we want to let these
games in? Why do we want to open these
doors to make it a harder challenge for
ourselves?
>> Choose ye this day who you will serve.
Guess what? the the path of destruction
is attractive
>> but choose stand there by the path and
look
>> okay this one is not going to be as fun
in my the nature that I you know the
nature that I have because of the fall
this one is more attractive but what do
I want do I want death or life that is
the two questions you ask that's the
only question
>> I believe that to be true
>> yeah I I one of my favorite books is uh
Pilgrim's Progress it's an allegory of
the Christian walk and the character in
it. It's actually named Christian. And I
I remember there's this section in there
and it's they actually made an animated
movie about this this book, too. It's
really good. It's on YouTube for free
called The Pilgrim's Progress. But
there's a section a chapter in the book
where he walks through Vanity Fair. And
Vanity Fair is supposed to be supposed
to be symbolic of all of the fanfare
around like all of the attractions and
and everybody's like having fun and
they're trying to sell you all of the
goods and they're like, "Buy for me
this, buy from me that," you know, and
and and Christian is walking with
faithful and and they walk through
Vanity Fair and they say, "No, we don't
want this. We don't want this." They've
been warned by evangelists, this is
going to be something really difficult
you guys have to go through. Long story
short, because they said no, they got
captured, they got imprisoned, they got
tortured, and faithful dies. That's why
he's called faithful. And Christian ends
up, you know, escaping and finishing the
pilgrim's progress until he gets to the
celestial city, which is called
considered heaven. Um but but you know
they were willing to rather lay down
their life and die and be martyed than
having and and sealing their fate for
eternity than have all of these
distractions from the world to take hold
of them and really they would lose their
soul over it right their eternity. So I
think that should be a mindset of us as
today. And for some people might think,
"Oh, that's extreme. You can't play
video games. I can't even play Wii
Sports." Well, that's up to you between
you and God. You have to pray about it
and and and ask the Lord and he he might
convict you on that. He might not.
That's between you and God. But I would
say, you know, like like like you said,
Robert, choose you they this day whom
you will serve. You know, as for me in
my house, we will serve the Lord. It's
it's worth it in my opinion to walk with
the Lord and to ask him, "Search my
heart, Lord. Show me where I need to
give something up. Show me." Because God
is not a God or a father who's just
sitting there being like, "Well, today
I'm going to take this thing from them
and they're just going to suffer." He's
sitting there saying,
>> "As a loving parent, I want to help you
grow. I want to help you become more
like me in perfection and love and
kindness and gentleness." Right? But in
order to do that, I have to take this
thing away from you because this hurts
you. This damages you and you can't see
it right now. You're having a hard time
with it because you're attached to it.
But if I take that away from you and you
allow me to because he never forces
himself upon us, then you will live a
better, happier life. You just have to
trust me. And I think that's what he's
trying to tell us. In in the end what we
have to give up in this earth on this
earth is we can't even imagine how much
better we will receive how much more we
will receive in heaven.
>> It will be cheap enough.
>> It will.
>> And just to clarify before you know you
get a wrong um idea of what I said is
that I said this is maybe the boring
road and this is the more attractive
road. But trust me, if you follow this
the straight and narrow, it is not
boring.
>> Let me just clarify that. It's an
amazing road to travel.
>> That's right.
>> Yeah. Once you once you give your heart
to the Lord,
>> young people always mention that too is
is like, you know, like, oh, these books
or or this particular activity or video
games or something is so exciting and,
you know, I just don't I just don't see
that excitement in the Bible. But I
think once you really truly fall in love
with God and you and you're reading
those things, it's like the pages come
to life and you see it everywhere and
and then just the prospect uh Marlo like
you said, you know, heaven is just this
like grand thing that that we can't even
imagine how good that's going to be. And
and so I think that the closer that I've
gotten to to my relationship with Jesus,
it's like the more excited I get. And
and it just takes that takes that like
sort of reforming of the taste buds,
right? When you when you when you eat
unhealthy food, it's like that's what
you crave, that's what you want. And and
then if you actually switch that and you
you begin to eat food that that actually
does good to your body, the more that
you do that and then you try to go eat
that unhealthy food, you're like, "Ah,
it doesn't even taste the same as this,
you know, wonderful vegetable thing over
here, you know." And so, um, I think
that it just takes a bit bit of time to
to really repry oritize your focus and
you'll see that God's ways are true and
just and and he can be extremely
exciting.
>> Yeah.
>> Amen.
>> If you look at the effects of that
carrot or whatever you were saying and
how it uh transforms your body and how
you can exercise without you know
without um stopping that is the most
amazing feeling. But also the song um
the things of earth will grow strangely
dim. That is true. It does. That's
right. And at the end, we will hate sin.
That's where we should all be. Hey, we
should all get to that point. I I I'm
not there yet. You know that I hate
every part of sin, but that's where we
should get to that point.
>> Amen.
[music]
>> [music]